The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
ERIC GRIMSON: Good morning.
Professor Guttag has to
be out of town today.
My name's Professor Grimson.
I'm going to be subbing
for him.
And just to show you how much
we value education here at
MIT, and especially in EECS,
you get the incoming
chancellor as a substitute
teacher.
So how cool is that?
All right, maybe
not very cool.
But I'm going to talk
to you anyway
for the next 50 minutes.
At the end of last lecture,
I think Professor Guttag
introduced dictionaries to you,
a really powerful type.
It's got a great capability,
which is it's a tool, a data
type that lets you association
almost any kind of structure
with a key.
So it could be that you're
associating keys with numbers,
you're associating keys
with strings.
But you could be associating
keys with other things,
including dictionaries.
And I don't know if he showed
this to you or not, but those
keys themselves can also
be really powerful.
It could be just a string.
But the key could also be a
tuple, or a list, an x- and
y-coordinate, or a set of
names, or other things.
So it's a really great data
structure to use.
Now, one of the things you could
ask, though, is, gee,
what if Python or whatever
language you're using didn't
come with dictionaries?
Could we still get
the same power?
And the answer is sure.
So I want to show you
a little example.
So on your handout, if we look
at this little procedure up
here at the top, key search, I
could build it out of lists.
I could just use a list as
my way of storing it.
So let's look at what
this procedure.
Says it says, OK, if I've got a
list, and I've got a key, K,
I could write a little loop that
just walks down the list,
saying, is the first part of
each element equal to the key
I'm looking for?
And if it is, I'll return the
second part of that element.
And if I get to the end of the
list, I haven't found it, I
return none.
So notice I'm making
a choice here.
I'm assuming that I'm storing in
the dictionary things that
are lists too long, key and the
associated value, another
key and the associated value,
another key and
the associated value.
But this would work fine.
So if I didn't have
dictionaries,
I could build it.
If I wanted to make things that
had a more complicated
lookup, I'd have to make
sure that that
equality test did it.
But you could see how
I might do it.
So the question then can be,
so why do we bother with
dictionaries, if we could
just use it with lists?
Here's my question to you.
So how long in this
implementation is it going to
take me to figure out if
something's in my dictionary?
Oh my god, he's asking
questions at 10
o'clock in the morning.
This is really terrifying.
Somebody help me out.
How long?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Probably on
average on the order
the size of the list.
ERIC GRIMSON: Yeah.
On average, it's going to take
me half the size of the list.
But that's the same thing as
being the size of the list.
So if that list is really
long, I'm toast.
If it's not in the dictionary,
in fact, I'm going to have to
go all the way through the list
before I get to the end
to decide it's not there.
So this is not as efficient an
implementation as we'd like.
Now, the flip that is you say,
OK, how long does it take for
the dictionaries, the built-in
associated retrieval that you
have inside of Python?
And the interesting answer there
is that that retrieval
is constant.
It takes the same amount of time
independent of the size
of the dictionary.
And that's wonderful.
We're not going to talk
about how today.
You're going to see that
later on in the term.
But it is something that drives
home, if you like, the
point that different
data structures
have different costs.
And while some are easier to
implement in, they may not be
as efficient, some may be a
little more difficult to
implement in, but they are
much more efficient.
And that's one of the great
things about dictionaries.
The second thing I think you
saw at the end of last
lecture, and I want to just
highlight in a slightly
different way, is I believe
Professor Guttag showed you a
little example of a very simple
translation function.
We had a little dictionary.
I'm going to give you a version
right here, and
un-comment it.
In fact, there's a little
dictionary that simply
associates English words
with French words.
And yes, it's pretty simple,
but it's a little way of
pairing those things up.
And the idea would be if I have
a sentence just a string
that consists of a bunch of
words, I'd like to translate
that English sentence, if
I can, into French.
And let's look at the code
that's going to do it.
I'm going to, again,
un-comment it here.
It's on your handout.
I want to walk you through it.
So first thing I'm going to do
is actually write a little
procedure the says, given a
word in English, I want to
find the corresponding
word in French.
And that's pretty easy.
It says, if you give me a,
word, and you give me a
dictionary, I'm just going to
look it up in the dictionary.
That's just that associative
retrieval.
It does all the work to go into
the dictionary, say, if
that's a key for something in
the dictionary, it's going to
give it back to me.
And in particular, I can get it
back by simply retrieving
it out of the dictionary.
And notice I'm doing this
a little more carefuly.
I'm not just directly going, and
saying, give me the thing
corresponding to the word in
the dictionary, because it
might not be there.
So that test basically says,
if the word is in the
dictionary, it'll return true.
And in that case, I get out
the corresponding element.
If it's not in the dictionary,
I'm just going to be stuck
with the English words, so we'll
just return the word.
Now, let's look at the
more fun part of it.
I now want to translate
a sentence.
And the sentence is
a string of words.
I need to find where
the words are.
I need to look them up.
I need to gather together
a translation.
So notice what the heart of this
thing does, right down
here in this part of the loop
that I'm going to highlight
right there.
Oops, I mis-did that.
Let me try it again,
right there.
What's that doing?
It's walking down
the sentence.
A sentence is some
big, long string.
And it says for each character
C in the sentence, I need to
find where the word is.
So I'm going to keep walking
along until I find a place
where there's a space.
So that first test there is
saying, if C is not a space,
just add it onto the
end of the word.
Oh, yeah, I need to have
inititalized word, which I did
right up here.
I said, let's set word to
just be an empty string.
So I'm just walking along the
sentence until I find a space.
Until I do that, I'm just
gathering together all of
those characters.
So I'm building up the word.
When I get to the place where
in fact C is a space, then
here's what I'm going to do.
I'm going to translate the word
using that procedure I
just wrote.
It looks it up in
the dictionary.
It either gives me back the
French word, if it's there,
and if not, it just gives me
back the English word.
And, oh yeah, I'm doing
a whole long sentence.
So I need to add it together.
So I'm simply going to add it
to the end of what I've
translated so far.
And I'm doing a slightly
funky thing in there.
I'm inserting a space in
between, just to keep the
words separate.
And of course, I need to have
initialized translation up
here, which I did, to
be an empty string.
So what's this do?
Walks along character
by character.
When it gets to a space, it
says, I've got a word.
Find the translation, add it
to the end of this other
internal variable,
and keep going.
And I'll do that until I get to
the end of that sentence.
And then I'll just return
the translation.
Nice little iterative loop.
And it's simply using
two pieces to
make all of this happen.
I lied too you-- sorry,
I didn't lie.
I misspoke to you.
Which is, what's that funky
thing at the end?
What's it returning?
It's returning this strange
thing this says,
"Translation," starting with the
first element, a copy of
all of that, plus a translation
of the word.
So what assumption am I making
about the inputs that causes
me to do this strange
thing at the end?
I'm actually making two
assumptions about my input.
But I'm making a particular
assumption.
Why do I not just return
translation when I'm done?
Why am I doing this
last piece?
Anybody help me out?
Boy, I notice everybody sits way
back at the back, where I
can't make any eye contact.
How do I characterize
words in my string?
They have to end with a space.
Ooh, is there a space at
the end of my example?
So I guess I haven't shown
you an example.
But I'm assuming if I give you
a sentence, you don't usually
have spaces at the
end of sentences.
So I'm making an assumption, is
that the words, except for
the last one, are characterized
by spaces.
So this last little piece here
is to get the very last word,
and translate it.
Because it won't be a space.
Let's try a couple
of examples.
Let's just un-comment these,
and see if this does it.
Yes, commenting them again
is not a good idea.
We'll go the other direction.
Looks like it did right.
John-- we should have translated
John into Jean.
I don't know what the hell Eric
is in French, but John
mange du pan, Eric
boit du vin.
John has that right.
He's eats bread.
I like to drink wine.
And, of course, tout
le monde aime 6.00.
Or in this case, everyone
likes 6.00.
You just got HASS credit, by the
way, for listening to me
do French really badly.
OK, as I said, I made an
assumption, which that the
words end in spaces.
What's the other assumption
I made here?
I know you're just looking
at the code.
But I made another assumption
inside of my code.
And it's always good
to figure out what
those assumptions are.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: That the first word is
a noun, so we don't have to
translate it?
ERIC GRIMSON: I didn't
assume that.
I could if I was doing a more
clever translation.
But I'm actually making
no assumptions
linguistically here.
I'll give you a hint.
How many spaces do I
have between words?
Just one.
I'm sort of building that
into this assumption.
It's a reasonable assumption
to make.
But it points out, if I wanted
to improve the code, I should
think about these other cases.
And of course, to build a real
translation system, I'd need
something much more
sophisticated.
So this shows you little
example of using the
dictionaries.
But I want to use this to lead
into the main part of today's
lecture, which is, why did I
write this separate little
procedure up here called
translate word?
I could have buried that
inside the code.
And the answer is twofold.
First one is it saves a
small amount of code.
If I'm going to use it in
multiple places, I don't want
to rewrite the code.
And that actually is valuable,
not just to save you typing.
It means I only have
to debug it once.
It's one piece of code.
But the real reason I wanted to
introduce it is it gives me
what you might think of as
modular abstraction.
Those are fancy words that
basically say I am isolating
that function in one place.
If I decide to change how I'm
going to translate words, I
don't have to search through all
of my code to find all the
places where I was using that.
I just need to change the
definition of that procedure.
And I agree, in a simple example
like this, it looks
pretty simple.
But if you've got a million
lines of code, you're using it
10,000 different places, you
don't want to have to find all
the places to change.
So this is an example of modular
abstraction, isolating
where that thing is.
And that is an example,
in fact, of a general
problem-solving principle we're
going to use, called
divide and conquer.
Divide and conquer is basically
the idea of taking a
hard problem, and breaking it
up into some simpler pieces,
or into smaller problems, where
those smaller problems
have two properties.
Small problems are easier to
solve than the original one.
More importantly, the solutions
to the small
problems can easily
be combined--
I want to stress easily--
to solve the big problem.
And we're going to look
at a bunch of examples
today to show that.
This is a really old idea.
Julius Caesar used it.
He did it in Latin.
My Latin is terrible, but it's
something like divide et
impera, which literally
means divide and rule.
That's how he created
the Roman Empire.
The British knew this
really well.
That's how they control the
Indian subcontinent
brilliantly for several
decades.
Ben Franklin actually knew it.
In particular, he knew how good
the British were at this.
So there's a famous quote.
You may well remember-- when he
signed the Declaration of
Independence, he said, quote,
"We must all hang together, or
assuredly we will hang
separately," meaning divide
and conquer is going to
be a real problem.
So second HASS credit for you.
We just did some history.
Why are we going to
use it today?
Boy, you're a tough audience,
I noticed, by the way.
That's all right.
We're going to use it today,
because we're going to use it
as a tool for problem-solving.
And in particular, we're
going to use it with
one particular example.
You're going to see divide and
conquer later on in the term,
when Professor Guttag talks
about algorithm design.
Today, I'm going to show you one
great technique for doing
divide and conquer kind
of algorithms.
And that is the technique
of recursion.
How many people here have heard
that term used before by
computer scientists?
OK, not to worry.
If you've heard it, you probably
think that it's a
really subtle programming
technique.
I'll let you in on a secret.
That's a PR job.
It's what computer scientists
tell you to make you think
that they're much smarter
than they really are.
It's not subtle, and
it's much more than
a programming technique.
And we're going to
talk about it.
Now, it gets used not just as
a programming technique.
It gets used two other ways
in computer science.
And I'm going to talk
about both.
It's both a way of describing or
defining problems, so it's
a way of characterizing a
problem independent of how we
might implement it.
And it is a way of designing
solutions.
So an example of divide
and conquer.
Let me give you an example just
to show you of why it's a
way of defining a problem.
Consider the part of the legal
code that defines the notion
of a natural-born US citizen,
and remind you, to be eligible
to run for president, which I
hope you all do, you have to
be a natural-born US citizen.
Definition has two parts.
Part number one, anyone born
within the United States is a
natural-born citizen.
Part number two, anyone born
outside the United States,
both of whose parents are
citizens of the United States,
is a natural-born citizen,
as long as one parent has
lived in the US.
A little more complicated.
What does that actually say?
Well, it's got two parts.
And that's what a recursive
definition has.
The first part is simple.
You're born here, natural-born
US citizen.
Notice the second part.
It says, you weren't born here,
you might still be a
natural-born citizen.
But what you have to do?
You have to decide if your
parents are US citizens--
which they could be by having
been born here, but there are
other ways to be naturalized--
and that may require you
determining if your
grandparents are US citizens,
which may require you to-- ah.
So you may have to chain down
several sets of problems.
Those two parts are what exactly
we're going to use
when we talk about recursive
definitions.
There's what we call a base
part, which typically
describes the simplest version
of the problem.
And then there is an inductive
part that tends to describe
how you reduce the problem
to simpler
versions of the same problem.
So in fact, let me write
those both down.
We have--
it's called a base case.
This typically gives
us a direct answer.
It just tells us very simply,
using very simple methods,
whether this is something that
satisfies that recursive
definition.
And there is the recursive
or inductive case.
Here, you reduce to a simpler
version of the same problem,
plus some other simple
operations.
OK, again, a bunch of words.
Let me show you some examples.
I'm going to start with three
or four different examples,
just to show you how
quickly we do this.
What I want you to see in all of
these examples is that when
I describe the problem, I'm
describing it in terms of
what's the simplest case, and
then how do I build solutions
to bigger problems from
solutions to smaller versions
of the same problems?
OK, here's the first case
I'm going to do.
Suppose I tell you I want to
build a little procedure to do
exponentiation, integer
exponents.
I want to compute b to the n.
But I tell you I've got a really
cheap machine, and all
I can do is multiplication.
So I can't use exp.
Mathematician--
a course 18 person would
say, what's b to the n?
That's b times b times
b, n times.
How could I solve this?
Well, recursively, I'd like to
say, suppose I could solve
smaller versions of
the same problem.
And if somebody gave me a
solution to that smaller
version, how would I
build a solution
to the bigger problem?
Oh, that's easy.
That's the same as b times
b to the n minus 1.
All right, I can see you're
all going, well, duh.
I guess that's what
chancellors know.
They're not very bright.
Of course, you know that.
But notice what I did.
I've now reduced it to a simpler
version of the same
problem, recursively.
This basically says I wanted
to solve b to the n.
It's b times b to
the n minus 1.
Oh, yeah, but I've
got to figure out
when to unwrap this.
So there's an if there.
And that's true as long as
n is greater than one--
actually, as long as n
is greater than 0.
We'll do it that way.
And if n is equal to 0, I know
the answer is just 1.
I know you don't believe me,
but that's really cool.
Why is it really cool?
What do I have?
I have a base case.
And if it's equal to 0, I know
the answer right away.
If n is bigger than 0, oh, let's
assume that I've got
somebody who will give
me the solution to
that smaller problem.
When I get it, I can
just use it, do the
multiplication, and I'm done.
And so, in fact, here is a
simple piece of implementation
of that, which I know is not in
your handout, but I'm just
going to show to you, because
I simply want you to see the
form of it.
It's an exact Python
translation
of what I just said.
It says, if I want to take an
exponent of b to the n, if n
is equal to 0, just return 1.
If not, solve a smaller version
of the same problem
right there.
Call to the same procedure,
same function,
but different argument.
And when I get that answer back,
just multiply it by b,
and return that.
This may look a little funky.
This is the kind of thing that
your high school geometry
teacher would rap your knuckles
with, although
they're not allowed to
do that anymore.
You don't define things in
terms of themselves.
This is not geometry.
This is programming.
And this is a perfectly
legal recursive
definition of a problem.
It will stop, because it will
keep unwinding those recursive
calls until it gets down
to the base case.
And I'm going to show you an
example of that in a second.
I want to show you a much nicer
example of recursion.
And again, part of my message
here is when you get a
problem, don't instantly
start writing code.
Think about, how do I break
this down recursively?
So I have brought some very
high-tech tools with me today.
This is my version of the
tower of Hanoi problem.
How many people know the problem
of the tower of Hanoi?
Only a few.
OK, so here's the story.
There's a temple in Hanoi
staffed by a bunch of monks.
In that temple, there
are three tall,
jewel-encrusted spikes.
Mine aren't nearly as fancy.
And there are 64 golden disks,
all of a different size.
Stack starts out on one of those
spikes, and the monks
move one disk at a time.
Their goal is to move the entire
stack of 64 from one
spike to another.
And the rules are they can it
of one disk at a time, but
they can never cover
up a smaller disk
with a larger disk.
I have to tell you, I don't know
what happens when they
move the entire stack.
I mean, the universe ends, or
you all get A's in 600, or
something equally as cool.
Question is, could we write a
piece of code to help the
monks, to tell them
how to move them?
All right, so let's
figure this out.
And I'm going to show
you some examples.
So I'm going to move a
stack of size one.
Well, that's not very hard.
Watch carefully, because
you're going to
write code to do this.
I want to move a stack of size
two, so I've got to just make
sure that I move the
bottom one off.
That's not so hard.
Now, I want to move a
stack of size three.
I've got to be a little more
careful, because I can't cover
up the smaller one with
a larger one.
But that doesn't
look very hard.
Got the solution, right?
Now, we go for stack
of size four.
This one definitely takes a
little bit more care, because
you really can't cover it up.
But as long as you do it right,
you can actually move
the-- oops, and I didn't
do it right.
You've got to move the pieces
in the right way.
I do this for taking money off
of Harvard students in Harvard
Square, by the way.
Got it?
Real easy to see the
solution, right?
You could write code
for that right now.
I'm not going to do five,
but it's really
easy to see the solution.
Yeah.
I blew it, too.
I did one move I had
to backtrack on.
Let's think about this
recursively.
What's the recursive solution?
Break it down into a simpler
problem, or a problem of a
smaller size.
Ah, here's the solution.
To solve this, I've got a stack,
I've got a stack I'm
going to, I've got
a spare stack.
What's the solution?
You take a stack of size n
minus 1, move it onto the
spare stack.
Now I've got a simple problem.
I can always move a
stack of size one.
And then I move a stack of size
n minus 1 to the target.
And, of course, how I move a
stack of size n minus 1?
Well, I just unwrap
it one more.
That's a really easy
explanation, right?
And it's really easy to write
code to do exactly that.
So let me show it to you.
Again, I know this isn't in
your handout, but I just
wanted to see it.
And you could write
this yourself.
I'm going to write a
little procedure
right here called Hanoi.
What are my arguments?
Going to tell how big
a stack there is.
That's m.
And I'm just going to give it
labels, the from stack, the to
stack, and the spare stack.
Look how simple the code is.
Says, if it's a stack of
size 1, just move it.
I'll just print out
the instruction.
Move it from the from
stack to the target
stack, or the to stack.
If it's bigger than
1, what do I do?
I move a stack of size n minus
1 onto the spare stack.
I move a stack of size 1, which
is what's left, onto the
target stack.
And then, I move that stack over
here that's on the spare
stack over to the
target stack.
It's what I just showed
you right there.
OK?
So let's try it.
Yes, I know I still
like French.
We're going to do Hanoi.
Move a stack of size 1.
And we'll just give this
some labels, just
from, to, and spare.
Well, duh.
You just move it there.
All right.
Let's try a stack of size 2.
It's just what I did.
I'm sure you remember that.
Let's be a little more
daring here.
There's the solution to move
a stack of size 5.
I'll let you check
it separately,
make sure it's right.
One of the things you
can also see here--
I'm not going to
talk about it.
You might think about it, ask
your TA in recitation is, how
long does it take to
solve this problem?
How long is it going to take
those monks to actually move a
stack of size 64?
I'll give you a hint.
The answer is measured
in billions of years.
This is an exponential
problem.
And you can see that
growth right away.
That's a separate topic.
But notice coming up with that
solution on your own, maybe
not so easy.
Thinking about it recursively,
very easy to think about.
And that's the way we
want to look at it.
OK, let me give you another
example of breaking a problem
down recursively, and then
writing the code to do.
I want to decide if a sentence
is a palindrome.
Remember what a palindrome is?
It is not an ex-governor
from Alaska.
It is a string of characters--
I guess an airport in Alaska--
it's a string of characters
that have the property
that they read the
same front to back.
The most famous one in English--
which is, of course,
amusing because it's attributed
to a Frenchman-- is
Napoleon supposedly saying,
"Able was I ere I saw Elba."
Same thing back to front.
How would I write a piece of
code to decide if something is
a palindrome?
I'm going to do it
in a second.
You've got it on the handout.
But let's think about
it for a second.
What would the base cases be--
or base case?
Somebody help me out.
What's a good base case here?
What's the shortest possible
sentence I could have?
I?
A?
Don't worry about whether it's
a legal sense of not.
It might need a verb in there.
Base case is presumably, if
I've got a string one
character long, it's
a palindrome.
If I've got a string zero
characters long, it's probably
a palindrome as well.
How would I take a longer string
and break it down into
a simpler version of the same
problem to decide if something
is a palindrome?
Anybody want to help me out?
Is that a hand up there,
or are you just
scratching your head?
Well-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: Maybe take the first
and the last element, see if
they're equal.
If they are, then cut
them off, and--
ERIC GRIMSON: Yeah.
What's a palindrome?
The easy way to start it is take
the things at the end,
first and last character.
If they're not the same, it
doesn't matter what's
happening in the middle.
This thing can't be
a palindrome.
So let's check those.
And oh, yeah, if those are the
same character, and I pull
them off, what do I have?
I have a smaller version
of the same problem.
I have a new sentence that's
now two characters less.
Do the same thing.
Say, is that a palindrome?
So if these characters
match, and that's a
palindrome, I'm done.
How do I tell if that's
a palindrome?
Check if their two end
characters match, and the
things in the middle.
So let's look a little piece of
code to make this happen.
I'm going to do it in
a couple of pieces.
Here's the first piece
I'm going to write.
I'm going to walk
you through it.
First thing I'm going to do is
I'm going to do this outside
of the recursive call is I
need to convert a string
that's put in to make
sure that, in fact,
it's in a form I want.
So I don't care about
the spaces.
Able was I ere I saw Elba.
The spaces aren't in
the same place.
That's OK.
It's really the characters.
And I don't really care
about capitalization.
So this little procedure
basically says, given a
string, convert it all into
lowercase-- and if you haven't
seen that, I'm just importing
from a module called string
some built-in procedures--
and this one simply takes
the string, and
makes it all lowercase.
And then what do I do?
Well, just like we did before,
I'm just going to walk down
that string, gathering
together all of the
characters.
So this little loop just says,
let's initialize ans to be an
empty string.
And then for each character
in s, if it is a lowercase
character-- and that little
test simply does that.
It says, if it's in the set of
lowercase characters I'm going
to add it to the end.
And when I'm done, I'm just
going to return ans.
Going to return the answer.
A little procedure.
And, by the way, this is a
nice piece of programming
style, as well.
I want to separate out things
that I want to do once from
the things I'm going to
call multiple times.
So I don't need to re-check
every time that my string is
all lowercase, I'm just going
to convert it out.
Now, let's look at how
do we test this.
Well, it's literally just a
translation of what we said.
But let's look at the pieces.
It says, if I give you just
a string of characters--
I've gotten rid of the spaces,
I've made it all lowercase--
what does it say to do?
I've got to check for
the base cases.
And here, I'm actually
going to be careful.
We could have discovered
this if we programmed.
There actually are two base
cases here, which is, is the
string of length one, or
is of length zero?
Why would I end up with
two base cases?
Why don't I just check for
a string of length one?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ERIC GRIMSON: Exactly.
I can have an odd or an even
number of characters.
So as I'm clipping them off the
ends, I might end up with
nothing in the middle,
or I might have one
in the middle exactly.
And we might have discovered it
if we tried programming it.
But right, exactly right.
So I can capture that by just
saying, if the length is less
than or equal to 1, which
gets both of those.
In that case, we know the
palindrome will return true.
Otherwise, what do we do?
Well, we do what the gentleman
over here suggested.
We take the first and the last
character of the string--
again, remind you s with an
index of minus 1 goes
backwards 1, if you like, and
gives me the last character.
If those two characters are the
same, I've now reduced it
to a simpler version of
the same problem.
So I simply say, if that's true,
and everything else is a
palindrome, return true.
Now, if you've not seen this
particular little funky form
right here, that is taking
string s, and saying, give me
a copy of everything starting
with the first--
which means not the
0th element--
and ending with everything up
to, but not including, the
last element.
We'll use this to make copies
of other kinds of lists.
But that's all that's doing, is
saying, give me what's in
that string, throwing away the
first and the last element.
And that gives me exactly the
recursive call I want.
I'm now saying what?
If the first and last character
are the same, and if
what's left over is itself
a palindrome, I'm golden.
Now, let me just wrap
all of that up in a
little piece here.
I'll un-comment this.
Which is simply going to say,
I'm going to print out, or put
a comment in it.
And I'm simply going to put
the two pieces together.
Given a string, I'm going to
convert it into all lowercase
characters.
And then I'm going to check,
is this thing a palindrome?
So again, let's try
some examples.
So we'll pick on Professor
Guttag.
His name is almost
a palindrome.
Not quite.
So we're going to give
him a name change.
It helps if I can type.
Oh, good.
Guttag is not, but Guttug,
whatever that means in German,
is, because the Gs, the Us,
and the Ts all match up.
Oh, and let's see.
Let's try a couple of
other ones here.
And I actually typed these in.
We'll check to see if Napoleon
really was right when he used
his palindrome.
If you can't read this last
one, it says, "Are we not
drawn onward, we few, drawn
onward to--" and I can't read
the tail end of that--
"to new era." And if we try
both of those, they are.
What's my point, you're
wondering.
I solved this problem by simply
breaking it down into
simpler versions of
the same problem.
That's the tool that you want.
If you were just trying to think
about, how do I keep
track of my indices as
I'm walking along?
I'm going to come in from
both ends, so I've
got to add and subtract.
And I got to make sure
I'm checking things.
You could write a nice
iterative loop
that would do it.
Actually, I'll take back
the word nice.
You could write an iterative
loop that would do it.
But it is not crisp, it's not
clean, and it's really
easy to screw up.
Or you could say, let's take
advantage of recursion.
Let's just break it down
into a simpler
version of the same problem.
You'd get a very nice,
simple piece of code.
Now, this may still feel
a little mysterious.
I wouldn't blame
you if it did.
So let's do the following.
I'm going to comment these out
so that we're not constantly
looking at them.
And I'm going to show you what
happens if we actually look
inside of this thing to
see what's going on.
So just give me a second here.
We're going to comment
all of those out.
And let's build a version of
this that just prints out as
we go along.
So I'm going to show
you right here.
It's the same basic pieces.
And actually, I realized
I need to leave
is characters around.
Let me go find my is
characters part--
two characters part.
Sorry, give me a second here.
Going to need that.
So we'll un-comment
that region.
That's just doing the
conversion for us.
I think this is going to work.
Let's look at what
we're doing here.
This is exactly the
same thing.
But I'm just going to put some
print statements in it, which
as I'm sure you've already heard
from Professor Guttag,
is a good thing to do as well.
I want you to see
what happens.
So the only changes I'm making
here are when I come into the
thing that's doing the checking,
I'm going to print
out a little thing that says,
what are you calling me with,
so you can see how
it does the work.
And then, if it's a base case,
I'm going to print out a
statement that says I'm
in the base case.
And otherwise, I'm just going
to print out something that
says, here's what I'm about to
return for the piece of the
string I'm looking at.
So it's just instrumenting, if
you like, what I'm going to do
inside of here.
And the other piece I'm going
to do is I'm going to have a
little space called indent, so
that every time I call a
smaller version of the problem,
I'm just going to
indent over a little bit, so you
can see how it unwraps it.
And if we do this, just
run that through.
Let's try it.
So if I call is palindrome
print with Guttag--
it would really help if I
could type, wouldn't it?
Yes, it would really help
if I could type.
You're all being really polite,
going, ah, he missed a
character there.
But we're not going to tell
him, because he's going to
have to figure it
out for himself.
Administrators cannot
possibly do this.
Ah, notice what it did.
This is how you can see the
recursive unwinding.
It said--
I'm going to check
this thing out.
It said way up there--
actually,
I'll just do it here.
It said, I'm going to call
it initially with Guttag.
Oh, the two Gs worked so
that recursively--
and notice the push-in here--
said, I'm calling it again
with U-T-T-A. Oh, that
one didn't work.
So I didn't have to check any
further, and I pushed it out.
On the other hand, if I do this,
ha, you can see all of
the stages.
You can see it unwinding it.
It says, to decide if Guttug
is a palindrome,
well, I check the ends.
And I've got to check U-T-T-U.
I don't know what that is.
Something interesting.
Which says, I got
to check that.
Which means I've got a check,
oh, there's that base case of
the empty one.
I can now return true-- and I'm
going to open this up so
you can see it--
from the base case, true
for that, true for
that, true for that.
Let's do one last one,
assuming I can type.
I can't.
Well, you get the idea, right?
It's a little messy.
But we go up a little bit,
you can start seeing--
I'm obviously just going to
run out of those pieces
there-- but notice
what it's doing.
It's stripping off each of
those characters in turn.
You can see how deep this goes
in, which is why you've got
all those weird spaces there
as I keep going in.
But it starts off by
saying, look at
that, oh, look at that.
I've got to look at--
[GIBBERISH]
Which says, I've got to
look at [GIBBERISH]
You get the idea.
But notice the key thing.
I'm simply reducing
it to a simpler
version of the same problem.
You can also see that to get
the answer out, I've got to
stack up a whole bunch
of things.
All those indents are basically
held operations,
which is one of the properties
of a recursive procedure.
You have to hold onto
intermediate things.
And that can cause,
in some languages,
some efficiency issues.
But in terms of solving the
problem, this is really easy.
I've just broken it down into
those simple pieces.
And that's really nice.
So let me finish up with
one last example
of a recursive procedure.
Again, my goal here is to let
you see, what am I doing?
I keep repeating this,
but it's important.
To solve a problem, figure out
how to break it down into a
simpler version of
the same problem.
One of the classic examples
of recursion is Fibonacci.
How many people here know
the Fibonacci numbers?
A few more, good.
For those of you who don't,
here's the story.
Probably heard the phrase, "They
breed like rabbits."
It's been used to describe a
population that the speaker
thinks is growing too quickly.
Works with rabbits.
It works if you put two
pennies in a drawer.
There's a whole bunch of ways
in which this happens.
The history of this is
actually very old.
It goes back to 1202, when an
Italian mathematician named
Leonardo of Pisa, also known
as Fibonacci, developed a
formula that he thought would
help him quantify the notion
of how rapidly do
rabbits breed.
And here was his model.
His model is not great, and
we'll see that in a second.
But here's his model.
You start with a newborn
pair of rabbits, one
male and one female.
You put them in a pen.
You assume that rabbits
are able to mate at
the age of one month.
And you further assume that
they have a one-month
gestation period.
So they can produce offspring
at the end of a month.
Finally, let's suppose that
these mythical rabbits never
die and that the female always
produces one new pair--
that is, a male and a female
every month from its
second month on.
The question is, how many female
rabbits will there be
at the end of a year?
Hm.
OK, let's see if we can
figure this out.
OK, at month 0, when it starts
off, there's 1 female rabbit
and 1 male rabbit.
At the end of the first month,
there's still one female
rabbit, but she's
now pregnant.
So there's still 1.
At the end of the second
month, what do we have?
Well, that initial female
is still there.
And she has produced one pair.
So there is a second female.
At the end of the third month,
that initial female has again
been pregnant and
has produced.
And these two are still there.
So there are 3.
At the end of the fourth month,
both of these females
have now produced offspring.
And those 3 females
are now pregnant.
There are 5.
At the end of the fifth
month, those 3 females
have produced offspring.
Those 5 are now pregnant.
There are 8.
And at the end of the sixth
month, there are 13.
What did I just describe?
I just described a nice
recursive relationship.
That says, gee, there ought
to be a base case.
And there ought to be
a recursive case.
And, in fact, in this case, we
can describe this very nicely.
The number of females at month
end is the number of females
there were two months
earlier--
because they've all given
birth, so that's
that many new females--
plus the number of females there
were at the previous
month, who are now
all in whelp.
Ah, that's a recursive
relationship.
If I wanted to figure out how
many females there are at
month end, what do
I have to do?
Well, I just have to say,
what's the base case?
Because there's the
recursive case.
And the base case is--
let me do it this way.
If n is equal to
0 or 1, it's 1.
And as a consequence, I should
be able to figure out how
quickly do rabbits breed, at
least according to 12th
century Italian mathematicians.
A couple of things to notice
here, by the way.
Sort of similar to what I saw
in the towers of Hanoi
problem, I'm going to have
multiple recursive calls.
To solve this problem of size n
over here, I've got to solve
two smaller problems, and then
do the simple operation of
adding them together.
That's OK.
It's going to change the
complexity of my algorithm,
but it's perfectly fine to have
multiple recursive calls.
And as I saw in my case of the
palindrome, I may have more
than one base case.
That's also OK, as long as
I can ground this out.
All right, so let's
just look at it.
How would we write this?
Let me get rid of that,
comment that out.
We can write a little
procedure to compute Fibonacci.
And there's the procedure.
It's in your handout.
I've got some things up at the
top here that are just making
sure that I got the right kinds
of arguments to pass in,
which is a cleaner, crisp
way of doing it.
But what do I say?
I say, if either x is 0 or x
is 1, two base cases, just
return the answer, which is 1.
Otherwise, solve two--
right there--
smaller sub-problems.
And what's the simple
operation?
Just add the two things
together, and return it out.
And if I do this, we can check
to see if we actually compute
Fibonacci properly.
All right, let's do
a test fib of 0.
It says, ah, fib of 0 is 1.
To do a test fib of 1-- there's
my other base case.
Aha, it says, there they go.
And now, let's do something
a little larger.
There it is.
As it gets each computation it's
doing, it says, to get
fib of 3, I've got to solve
fib of 0, fib of
1, and fib of 2.
And there's the answer.
And just to make sure we're
really doing this well, just
reproduce my table over there.
Do I expect you to get all
of that code right away?
No, although it's pretty
easy to understand.
What I do expect you to see,
though, is notice what I did.
I took a recursive problem,
and broke it down
into simpler pieces.
And then I used the solutions of
those pieces to give me the
solution to the larger
problem.
By the way, Leonardo
Pisa had it wrong.
In 1859, as I'm sure many
of you know, a wonderful
Australian farmer named Thomas
Austin imported 24 rabbits
from England to use as
targets for hunting.
10 years later there were 2
million rabbits being shot and
trapped in Australia.
And fib, while it grows fast,
doesn't go quite that fast.
So Leonardo of Pisa
had it wrong.
Of course, as you probably also
know, Australia, and I
think New Zealand, have the
wonderful property of having
more sheep than people.
I don't know what that says,
other than it's a great
recursive problem.
Fibonacci, by the way, actually
shows up in other places.
Again, it may not be a perfect
model of rabbit populations,
but it has some other really
interesting properties.
One of them is, if you let n get
close to infinity, and you
look at the ratio of fib of
n over fib of n minus 1--
it sounds like a strange
thing to look at.
It basically tells you how
quickly does fib grow.
Does anybody know the
answer to this?
The golden ratio, 1 plus root
5 over 2, which Leonardo--
the other Leonardo, the really
good Leonardo-- by the way,
used to design buildings with.
So there's a very strange
connection.
The other one thing I like about
this is that Fibonacci
shows up, actually,
a lot in nature.
So, for example, did you know
that the number of petals on
most flowers is a Fibonacci
number?
For example, black-eyed
Susans, 13 petals.
Field daisies, 34 petals.
You might ask why.
Oh, sorry.
I'm out of time.
I won't answer it today.
But you can ask Professor Guttag
next time around why it
is that petals come in
Fibonacci numbers.
What's the message
of this lecture?
Recursion, divide and conquer.
Break a problem down
into simpler
versions of the same problem.
Life is really easy.
And you'll see Professor
Guttag next time.